boom are you doing there how you doing
happy birthday to you man happy birthday
you got millions of people wishing you a
happy birthday thank you thank you it
was yesterday was my birthday ironically
it's Buddha's birthday also nothing
Buddhist but it's Buddha's birthday but
it's one of the happiest days of my life
you know for so many twenty-something
years I've been saying this crisis was
coming and it's here it's a it's a
probably a perverse or sick way of being
happy but it takes a lot of courage to
just keep saying what I think is going
to happen is what happened so now it's
happened and so I celebrated yesterday
now it's time to get back to work and
what a better way to get back to work
with my friend Patrick McDavid good to
be on with man I've really enjoyed the
time we've been spending lately thank
you thank you it's your show man and
thank you everybody for joining in so
robert woody is so obviously i remember
your your prediction years ago that you
made with what's gonna happen with the
market and now it's becoming a reality
how are you processing all of this stuff
yourself well it's like anything else
you know that theory is one thing
reality is another and it's frightening
you know minutes I I'm more
compassionate
I don't know how families are taking it
I'm okay because I was ready for it you
know I mean my wife and I Kim were just
sitting there having expensive bottle of
wine toasting each other because we made
it we came through heaven and hell to
make it and it was worth the journey but
to to not know if what I was forecasting
was gonna come true was self-doubt you
know we all have self-doubt so that's
what we celebrated so we celebrate and
like I said let's time to move on the
prediction you're talking about here's
rich dad's prophecy and our son writing
this book in 1999 and it was about the
crash that would come in 26
gene well they came four years later
2020 but I didn't foresee 1999 I didn't
foresee quantitative easing and money
printing I just didn't see how dastardly
the more you know how the people that
control the world
are and then to have it come through via
a virus or what nauseam Talib calls the
Black Swan even more dastardly and then
to shut down the whole world's economy
and put millions of people out of work
and destroy you know small business
owners the lifeblood of the world to
save the rich the really really rich is
I think criminal criminal so I saw the
brand yesterday happy birthday to me
nice bottle of wine and it's time to
move on with my friend Patrick McDavid
I'm sure people want to know what was
the bottle of wine just out of curiosity
what were you we can drink him it's one
of my best friend's name is John Shaw's
boss a JCB and his excellent wine he
owns a lot of wines because he comes
from the private equity side too but
he's on the fence but he's a French guy
who owned who owned bender it's his
family own vineyards in France so he's
for real then he went to business school
learned private equity and now he owns
most of the vineyards in FFL also and
then he met his sweetheart
her name is Gina Gallo of Gallo White's
so they are dynasty if you know we're
talking about here so they're too much
dynasty in wines and one American
dynasty and they're the most magnificent
people just magnificent people so anyway
life is full of really good hard-working
people and you know Gino is you could
call her a rich girl she busts her butt
you know Kim and I really became friends
with her because they're entrepreneurs
both are entrepreneurs rich
entrepreneurs but they don't stop
working you know they love what they do
they're passionate and all that and
they're kind people and that's as you
know Patrick very rare today very rare
so the gallows and the boss a JCB great
people
it's a great combination right there
well good for you for enjoying a wine so
Robert any good news for us with all
this craziness 2.2 trillion dollar
stimulus they're talking about it's
going to go to ten trillion dollars some
are even seven on employments going to
go to 30 plus percent by you know late
q2 any good news or any good predictions
you have for the rest of us I don't know
if it's good news except to be careful
you know what changed my life was a book
like it did for many people it was this
book it was called a Grunch of giants
and it's by dr. R Buckminster Fuller and
Greg stands for gross Universal cash
hikes so when I was I think in my 30s I
went to study with fuller you know he's
most well-known for the geodesic dome
and I first saw his geodesic dome in
Montreal Canada Expo 67 the World's Fair
on the future so my classmate from
school in New York we hitchhiked up to
Montreal
just to see Bucky's dome it was a u.s.
pavilion and it blew me away you know
and but we all have these events and
teachers in our lives and so I think the
good news is is that there's a teacher
like you online now the best teachers
are on YouTube not in schools anymore
and I think that's really the good news
is this what we're doing is the news
what's happening in the news today is
fake is the old news this is tragic
this coronavirus you know like I don't
know what's real I mean the virus is
real but the media terrorism is
frightening so I've already been warned
many times to stay in my lane don't go
into medicine don't go into this virus
stay teaching people with my little cash
flow game you know I'm talking about
stay small oval stomp on you so I just
remember back in nineteen side I first
went to the dome in Montreal at the
World's Fair in 67 and I studied with
fuller in 1981 and I started in 81 82
and 83 and he
predicting the future yes he told us
what was coming and as I've said many
times many people it's not what I want
to do I don't do what I love I asked
myself what does God want done and what
God wants done is edging is real
education my opinion and it's financial
education and there is no real financial
education our school systems and that's
not a mistake so I that was an 81 and 83
I couldn't take it anymore I read a read
brunch of giants and I understood it
because my rich dad kept saying
somebody's messing with us and every
time he said that you know you're a tin
hat guy your aluminum hat you're a
conspiracy
you're a spaceship or an alien guy into
saying now I'm an entrepreneur at the
time I was in rock and roll yeah my
first date with Kim was to the place you
know and and she was off fun having a
good time and I wasn't back with the
attorneys negotiating a contract so I'm
not really a rock and roller but I'm an
entrepreneur and at that time I said
what does God want done not what I want
to do I love rock and roll and what God
wants done is financial education I was
my opinion but then and that wasn't 83
so yesterday you know I sighs I don't
know if I'm if that's what I'm supposed
to do it because you'll never know
you'll never know what God wants done so
I operated on faith and yesterday I was
drinking my JCB wine celebrating with
Kim we made it we're financially free
but more than everything else were
prepared with a business that teaches
financial education to the masses
you see education is rigged as you know
it's only if you have money you know
that I know that you know your public
school system in America is based upon
real estate taxes so if you live in a
rich neighborhood your schools get more
money because the real estate pays for
it we live in a poor neighborhood you
get the poorest education because the
real estate taxes aren't high so
everything's about money but for some
reason we don't teach money at school so
that's why I kind of woke up in 83 I
said I can't be a
control America as much as I like that's
where you put please Van Halen Boy
George Duran Duran and those guys it was
six drugs rock and roll it was the best
of life and I said I think I'd better do
I think what God wants done not that I
wanted to do it but I was kind of
qualified to teach so that's why you're
my brother we're both teachers and you
know and we're teaching and what's new
is filled Instagram which I have no idea
what it is cause that's the old guy but
I think this is what God wants done and
I tasted a young people the Millennials
you know you've been screwed you know
you being left for the world that's
absolutely horrible shape financially
and all this student loan debt pensions
are collapsing financial systems are
collapsing the rich are getting richer
but apparently somebody gave you
something to get yourself out of this
and what the Millennials have that I
didn't have was an iPhone the iPhone is
a single most powerful I cannot believe
how much power that thing has so it
seems to me I'm not really religious I'm
not not political what I'm saying that
God does provide at some level and God
provided the Millennials with an iPhone
holy Mac all you have to do is sync your
brain to that iPhone you have more power
than you and I ever had when we were
their age you know do you not me the
trouble is if they don't haven't gone to
school and they have a teacher that is
incompetent and we've all had any
competent teachers their brain and the
iPhone are not synced in to making money
should I mean there and if you can't
make money with your iPhone there's
something wrong in your brain not the
iPhone screen and that's why I tell
young people so you and I on the news
Patrick what we're doing right now is
the news and Kovan bacteria and the
crash of the economy is the old news
it's a death so you and I on you right
now and that's the first morons Fuller
said to my class in 1981 there was a
hundred of us knows about 35 at the time
and he says ladies and gentlemen we are
the news what's in the newspaper is all
was in the newspaper at the time was
Reagan and Star Wars and Russia and
nuclear power and all that stuff he says
that's the death of an old and so in 81
he says in 1989 or what he said was full
of us of futurists one of the greatest
futures were ever had and he said before
the end of this decade which was 1980 a
new technology will emerge and the
future will be shown to us so in 1989
Berlin Wall came down so exactly as he
said you're sorry passed on he was gone
in 83
so 89 the Berlin Wall came comes down
which was the war between you know
Russia and Reagan and Star Wars and all
that other stuff nuclear power in 89 the
world wide web came up so exactly as he
predicted so all you young Millennials
out there and young people you have the
most powerful tool ever created in
humanity the question is how are you
gonna use it when you said iPhone the
way we're doing it right now to educate
to inspire to teach or you can watch
porn I want it
what's up to you it's really up to you
porn typically wins 80% of time just so
you know this Robert do you know porn is
gonna be when when the mind of a 18 year
old sitting there saying porn up you
know versus let me go educate myself
over here porn up ones 80% of time but
you got 20% that don't so you know a
couple things you were saying was so
interesting yesterday I had
Danielle DiMartino booth here okay do
you know yes she's fantastic she's a
great economist she's she was with the
Federal Reserve nine years Dallas
Federal Reserve and she wrote the book
called fed up and she said something
very interesting I'm curious to know
what your take is on this I talked to
her about the whole 2.2 trillion dollar
stimulus package how it's going to tend
show you right now I said who's gonna be
affected the most you know you got all
these different generations who's gonna
be affected emoticon the other one as
well and she said the most interesting
thing to me she says look the rich and
the wealthy they're gonna get wealthier
they're now going to be affected by at
all
the poor are not going to be affected by
it I said why not the poorest to speak
has added all the unemployment checks
that they're sending with the ten
million people that apply for
unemployment last month twenty five
percent of the people that are getting
unemployment checks they're getting
bigger checks than they were when they
had a full-time job
amen amen insane to think about that
right and so I would rather be
unemployed getting a check than being
fully employed that's 25 percent
she said the ones that are gonna take
the biggest hit is those who make fifty
eight thousand dollars a year two
hundred fifty thousand dollars a year
even two quarter million dollars here
because even a quarter million people
think quarter million is rich quarter
million is not rich after taxes you only
keep in about 140 of it right those
people who are working had one of my
employees came up to me to my office we
have over a hundred employees we have
14,000 agents nationwide and 130 offices
one of my employees came up to me and he
got emotional and I said why are you
emotional he says and he's somebody that
makes sixty sixty thousand dollar a year
income let's just put a number like that
he's somebody that's not a director not
a executive not just somebody that does
his job but he's very efficient at what
he does
his wife makes 325 a year okay she's a
very solid executive for another company
he comes in he says bad my wife was just
fired I said really says yes I said your
wife makes good income says yeah she
made 320 last year I said how's she
gonna replace that so she's not gonna
replace that oh no plums not gonna cover
any of that stuff I said how about
severance well with this job she only
been there for two years and good enough
for severance for two years just so
what's the plan now most people would
think that family is gonna be okay but
320 cost-of-living three kids private
school all that stuff they're gonna take
a hit so what do you think about this
whole thing that the rich are gonna be
fine the poor are gonna be fine but
those aren't the middle income category
taking the biggest hit
well let me say again it's because of
this book crunch grocery love Russell
cash ice I could see the future Fuller
was a futurist and this other book here
prophecy and I called it a 2016 these
are all warnings it was coming and I'm
not the only guy doing this you know as
Jim records who's that Danielle
DiMartino booth has done it so many
people have done it
except the people don't listen that's
the problem and what we are are your
chicken littles all the sky is falling
the sky is falling but why can't people
hear that
so records and I jump records you know
he wrote road to ruin and aftermath and
things like this we've all we've been
saying it's been coming for years but
the average person cannot hear it and I
think that's the problem and so what a
prophet becomes as a Cassandra a
Cassandra is a person who can see the
future
but nobody will listen to them it's kind
of funny isn't it
and the question you and I are always
asking us how come people can't hear it
looks like just now I got hammered
because I said I this coded virus thing
is overblown I can attacked and it says
you don't love your family the way I
love my families I don't don't you love
your family but it's your fear that's
the problem you know if you can't
control fear and that's why I really
love your last thing about you know a
war leader and a peacetime leader that
is one of the most powerful things you
know distinctions I've made because you
and I both served and all this death and
once you go to a war you're different
than the guy who didn't even join the
service so when I came back from Vietnam
I went there twice and once I crossed
into combat you know there's one thing
to be a Marine but when you cross the
line into Vietnam and you have to kill
people your life changes and when I came
back from Vietnam in 73 Johnny Weir E
3rd 1973 I arrived at Norton Air Force
Base I was a different human being and
then I could go out into the streets and
all these hippies are screaming at me
spitting on me throwing eggs on me our
instructions were ladies and you know
gentle no there's no women at the time
in the military what you talkin in a
combat unit I was a pilot you change
your clothes right away and try and
blend in because they your
your own Americans will try and kill you
and my particular
think happened as a lot of those hippies
became schoolteachers and now they carry
that education into our school system
Wow so that's why Jordan Pederson with
just about powerful yeah he says that's
why Jordan Peterson says the most
important thing to a school teacher is
word called tenure job security
paychecks pensions and that's what they
teach their kids subliminally you know
it's a your your your fragile and that's
him telling you now seem Talent the
great guy born Black Swan and anti
fragile aces we're teaching kids to be
fragile don't they need to be protected
you know fragile means you like a glass
of champagne fluid that shatters and
never gets put back together so millions
of young people are coming out fragile
like a champagne glass and a lot of the
military guys are like the second
category which is the real bust you know
we like rocks you can pound on US pound
than us pound list we won't break but we
don't grow we remain rocks and yet well
have friends west old rocks you know
they're gonna take it they're gonna cut
it out they're gonna get through this
crisis but what talent was talking about
this another carrot category called anti
fragile and he said it was the best way
to describe it it was against the
fragile person because they have so many
fragile people today and that's what
you're talking about a war leader and
peacetime leader our peacetime leaders
are putting out fragile champagne
glasses Marine rains call them [ __ ]
you know the sign to your [ __ ]
and so an anti fragile person will come
out of this smarter stronger better more
able to take on the world so the reason
what fuller said to me back in 81 to our
classes we are the news so today as the
world is collapsing behind us with the
stock market and employment businesses
are collapsing and it's fake it's not
real they're doing it to do it some of
us will come out anti fragile we'll come
out strong
better more able and that's why I said
when I saw that iPhone come out I said
all you Millennials on all you
entrepreneurs out there that cell phone
is your lifeline out of this mess
use it so what we're doing today is anti
fragile you know
we're wartime leaders and we're gonna
come out of this better I don't know how
but it's called metamorphosis
you know metamorphosis is like when a
butterfly I mean a caterpillar turns
into a butterfly that's been amorphous
and the definition of metamorphosis you
can look it up the dictionary is the
trend or the transformation from an
immature form to an adult form immature
form to adult form in other words grow
up so for some of us this crisis will
grow up will come of an anti fragile
will come out stronger and that's why
I've been watching my tweets I say no
the best teachers are on YouTube not in
school because most school teachers and
this was Jordan Peterson is saying he's
Jordan Peterson's being attacked by his
own school teachers because they aren't
[ __ ] you know they're all these guys
that made ten their day jobs he can't
even eat protection the world's a
terrible place capitalists are crooks
and all this stuff and it's a free
country you can listen to those guys if
you want or you can listen to Pat
Patrick McDavid so your thing on the
military leader versus the peacetime
leader was prescient it was some of the
most important lessons every punish to
look at they have to ask yourself today
am I going to be a military leader and
come out of this anti fragile and
stronger better healthier or am I going
to be crushed by what fuller called
Grunch the gross Universal cash lice
what Jim raucous talks about the
academic elite crushing us you know you
go to school today you come out weak so
there was some you know there's so many
books out as how our schools are failing
our students so really that's really the
choices as we listen to the tenth degree
right now which I have no idea what it
is because I'm so old yeah just turn 73
you know you're old you can't remember
how many years so anyway I mean it's
really the most exciting time it's also
dangerous it's very dangerous so be very
careful because the moment I start
tweeting about the corona the corona
virus whatever it is I was told stay in
my lane stay in my lane we'll get you
and that's exactly what fuller said back
in 81 he says if I told the world what I
know was really going on they would kill
me and so in 82 I don't look I'm about
35 years old and he says unfortunately
ladies and gentlemen you don't be up to
your generation the baby boom generation
to straight this out and it says be
careful because they won't kill you and
as you know some of the people that dr.
who blew the whistle on to in wuhan the
virus he disappeared people do disappear
I have a friend as a hitman for the CIA
he says people disappear if you step on
Grunch gross universal cache lice they
won't come and get you so what you and I
are doing right now is very dangerous
for our personal lives our professions
and all this so all you listening out
there it'll be wartime bitter but don't
be stupid watch what you say you know
it's crazy I got a a a professor from
Boston a very well-known professor sends
me a message this morning and one of the
guys immediately afterwards sends me a
message and he says there is this
dialogue going on with teachers being
very scared right now I said why is that
he said professors at universities are
frightened the last three weeks Why Why
are they frightened well because they're
worried the fact that if we threw this
pandemic it's kind of backfiring on them
this whole shutdown think is backfiring
on the educational system because
everybody's questioning well maybe I
don't need to go pay $50,000 a year to
go to college why
does a Harvard have sixty billion
dollars in him endowment I don't know
what their numbers if he came polyp
universities with the biggest and dime
and I want to give the right number why
do I need to go to college why do
parents need to take money out of our
there there for monkeys and cents mom
why do kids parents need to refinance
their homes and send their kids out so I
think in a way this is also going to
eliminate and hurt a lot of industries
that have been the you know monkey see
monkey do well I want my kids to go to
the best schools why because that's what
John Doe sent his daughters to and I
need to do the same and he's gonna go
get his fine arts degree from UCLA and
I'm so proud of that paper that says
UCLA yet I want to spend two hundred
thousand dollars you're seeing a lot of
industries today shivering who haven't
adapted to the current times and one of
the ones is gonna be the educational
system obviously we've been talking
about this a lot when you're talking
about you know the best teachers
nowadays are on YouTube or they're
creating content and they're making
people question and this tool the iPhone
tool is a powerful tool because the
Millennials can really listen to the
right content to get them to challenge
the conventional thinking but there's
got to be a lot of Dean's
around the world that are shivering
saying look I mean art model maybe
question right now our model may be
challenged right now our model may not
be the best way in the future because
you know I'm having to you know spend
time with my kid and we we don't
homeschool but I got an eight-year-old a
six year old and a three year old Here I
am homeschooling right now Here I am
finding a way to run two companies and
do what I'm doing on top of that I'm
also homeschooling my kids because I'm
forced to do so it's making me think is
the current model the real model and
maybe our capabilities are going to be
different and so I think colleges are
gonna take a very big hit with the
educational system with this taking
place and then the other thought is also
the fact that you said something you
said you know the the the author of the
book the by the way people who are
asking what the title of the book is
that put the link below it's called if
you can go back to so we can put it the
Grunch
of the Giants we'll put the link below
for some of you guys I want to get the
book that a robber was talking about to
make sure you guys can get him we'll
also put the link of the wartime video
for some of you guys I want to watch it
Robert what are you thoughts about this
what are you thoughts about this you
know the quote I'm quoting somebody I
just don't know who it is the person
said hard times produce strong leaders
strong leaders produce good times good
times produce weak leaders weak leaders
produce tough times so again tough times
produce strong leaders strong leaders
good times good times
weak leaders weak leaders tough times if
this is tough times does it mean the
last generation were producing wheat
leaders what are your thoughts about
that it's corrupt leaders the difference
between weak and corrupt and the
corruption starts in our education
system like I said when I was standing
there at Norton Air Force Base in 19
January of 1983 I'm being spit on and
eggs thrown at me way to change our
clothes and I just come back from war
time so as you know we've talked about
the wartime leader is very different I
don't think anybody ever knows the grief
it is what a aircrew doesn't return they
were a carrier pilots and you stand
there for hours hoping your friends come
back and and they're M IAS today there's
still a my a we don't know what happened
to them they just disappear you know and
there's a sadness and a grief that's so
profound and so when I come back I land
at Norton Air Force Base again and they
spinning on man going and then later on
I meet guys you know the boomers said
what you doing during Vietnam just oh I
was I was in Canada I was in college and
all this I hate to say it but sort of my
respect for them goes down a little bit
and you want to sound insane because
you've been there you know what war is
like you know what dying is like so you
can't explain it to and they can't even
explain to somebody who never joined the
military you know somebody who dodged it
so we're all different human beings and
we have different levels of tolerance
and fear and all this stuff I'll just
say this much you know is my piss being
on you guys started waiting for the
first time
I had one it was twelve thousand seven
hundred likes you know most people don't
get a thousand I got 12,700 but I also
got warnings stay in your lane
because I was crossing into
pharmaceuticals because I think that you
know gates just announced he's got a
vaccine really but if you understand
where the money is is that when somebody
produces a vaccine and Trump had to buy
in on it it's a friend of my Trump's you
have to buy it because they're going to
push this vaccine through the system and
that means everybody must be vaccinated
as pharmaceuticals so I was told to stay
in my lane it's a good warning dude I
mean I take the morning I mean and all
this stuff cuz that's not the battle I
want to fight so if I could say
something else I give people a better
idea it has more than crunch of giants
for that for many books but he talked
about that days he called it the five
minutes and so the mind is they control
that that Grunch controls academics
there's no financial education so they
controlled our mind then to control the
money that's Daniel G DiMartino booth
the Fed the fit is not federal it's a
it's a cartel or drug cartel then you
have military military industrial
complex you know I woke up in Vietnam
said why am i killing innocent people
why am i friends dying what am I doing
here
Who am I fighting for and then you have
the media so right now we're stepping on
media's tails you know and be my friend
is Steve Burke of NBC Universal mister
you guys are crushing us that's a lot
we're just little guys was life home so
media scared and then medicine so what I
what I have been doing just by tweeting
about Bill Gates and vaccines it
involves the minds and the and if you
don't fuller says you know most people
ha I love my children that's why I'm
afraid I love so it's love
you know I don't want my kids to get it
so we're gonna vaccine everybody and if
you don't vaccine I'll kill you because
you're gonna damage my kids so it's love
and hate are very close to each other
and so the media controls us by love and
hate and fear and then you have the
military and as you know this the
National Guard's in place already
protecting our toilet paper but there
are farther reasons - civil unrest which
is coming and then our money supply so
what happened for me is when I read
Grunch of giants I made the decision I
would never need money again and that's
when I chose to listen to my rich dead
my rich there was an entrepreneur and my
poor dad was an academic a poor academic
who was teaching kids to be fragile job
security steady paycheck and pension so
that's what about this quote this years
who stole my pension we haven't seen
anything yet Patrick you know when the
baby boomers wake up not only as a
Coquette virus nailed them because
they're old and feeble but Wall Street
has sucked all the cash out of their
pension plans so we haven't seen the
worst of it yet so that's why I'm saying
to you and your people that follow you I
would thought you know if those are you
following Patrick he is a wartime leader
you need a wartime leader right now
because what are really what a more time
leader fights for his peace you know all
I wanted was peace I was out there
fighting for peace but you have to be
very courageous to do that so I commend
you Patrick for doing that and all of
you following please listen to him
because we're in very dangerous times
right now because we are messing with
the my with the university system they
make so much money
student loans you know student loans -
they are 1.7 trillion dollars the
subprime mortgage was only one trillion
dollars so we screw the kids how dare we
do that and then you got money not
thing about money at school and if you
really have a real financial
transformation you don't need money you
can just make money like this and then
if you've served in the military you'll
understand what real courage is and that
was the word I got you know I went to
military school in New York only because
I was such a screwed-up kid in Hawaii
surfing all the time and so I needed
some discipline and when I meet people
are not successful they lack discipline
it's not that they're not smart
you know they can't it's not save money
they can't budget money you know right
now there's I saw my friend sister Ashe
is that what's yours what's your sister
dances well she's at home having sex
with her boyfriend I said well we're
gonna have a population explosion from
this thing you know then they can't
afford to take care of their kids
because they don't know have any money
and their employees they'll pay high
taxes and the media right now is shake
in their boots because what we're doing
threatens that they cannot control us
and then we have medicine so when I was
35 years old sitting in Fuller's
audience and he's brought in many books
Grunch was not his best book I don't I
wouldn't say I would have bother reading
it personally but I understood it so
that's what we are today Patrick and
what we're doing is the news and our job
is to be wartime leaders and be brave be
courageous get our skills up get our
entrepreneurial skills up you know learn
to sell learn to communicate don't learn
you know my problem
Patrick is I infuriate people because I
attack being a Marine is not bright
because I like to fight and that's why I
had to go to military school to
discipline myself so that's if any if
any of you out there you know have young
people you know I have a lot of friends
whose sons are wimps
there's just whips you know they're
sitting at home sucking their thumb and
now that they lost their job they want
to go back and get a job or exactly as
you said they all make more sitting at
home sucking their
and we've lost another generation there
so it really is time to be a wartime
leader in a wartime leader they know if
you've seen them some of the greatest
generals there's a big the best
gentleman I've ever met you know my
roommate on the carrier you know both
lieutenants you know uh you know and we
both flew together in Vietnam well I got
kicked out because of disciplinary
problems thing so I left them I left the
Marine Corps as a lieutenant you know
they didn't like me flying women and
drinking beer well on duty and that's my
thing I understand discipline now you
know but my roommate Jack went on to
become a lieutenant general so I said we
both came out lieutenants why was a
lieutenant general and I came out of
lieutenant but now he's a congressman in
Congress you know he's still fighting
you're still a peacetime here so the
generals I know as some of the greatest
human beings I've ever met
they rise to the surface and you know
lieutenant's like me get kicked out
and I'm proud of it I'm glad I did it
but I wouldn't do it again because it
was a very good drawing experience if
you know what I mean and I just had fun
the you know they give you a I give a 27
year old kid a helicopter and a credit
card and I was flying out of Hawaii and
there was a lot of remote beaches that I
used to go and visit with beautiful
young women you know I wouldn't
recommend doing it but I'm glad I did it
it's character spirit I like that it's
alright I know Pat let me tell you what
happened it's like a court-martial you
know they should have court-martialed
so I walked in and I was to remember
that the captain was captain Abram he
was a prosecutor and I was lying through
my teeth so he's finally one day I had
this transformational event I did a
thing called past est Erhard seminars
training everybody did it you know now
this and I sat in this room and I
realized I was a liar and I realized
that's well never be successful
because I could lie cheat and steal
that's very good at it and so I called
up captain Abrams and I was living in
Hawaii in Waikiki I was making a lot of
money in real estate but I called
captain Abrams and I said captain I'm
coming in what do you mean you coming in
I said I'm gonna come in I will tell you
what I know you couldn't believe it you
know I just realized if I didn't confess
my sins of the Catholic would say I'd go
to hell you know hell is not in hell
hell is I live with my lying cheating
stealing every day of my life so I took
the stand and he deposed me I told the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth I told him every criminal
event they weren't really criminal there
are petty thieves and I did stupid
things like fly this did this you know a
machine-gun goats from a helicopter and
I said I did all this at the end about
three and a half hours I think I lost 20
pounds and he said I said since captain
guess I'm gonna go to jail he says no
just thank you for telling the truth
gave me an honorable discharge it was
one of the most profound
transformational you know metamorphosis
he go from it in mature form to an adult
form I grew up I said holy mackerel the
truth will set you free
I understand that at a level that the
average person will never know because I
had been such a scumbag dishonest
disciplinary problem and then you know
like with my wife I've never cheated on
her most of my friends cheat on their
wife 70% do but when I said I'd get
married this time I would not cheat on
her marriage is still hard but cheating
makes it worse if you know what I mean
so it's a matter of not trying to change
the world out there you know the crisis
is between this year and this year and
in your heart and yeah being a military
leader or wartime leader is important
those with the textbook it's about
courage of this time
it's about being truthful being
forthright being upright being a
stand-up guy that's the difference today
and it's not about what the crooks are
doing is what you're doing if weak if
your mind was a computer and I was to be
able to go into a search the files I
wonder what kind of documents I would
find in that computer of yours you just
went from coronavirus to educational
system to Bill Gates to vaccine to Bill
gay here to helicopters to women to
booze to lieutenant general to
lieutenants to get now to cheating on
wives to 70% to friends your mind is
like constantly going with a bunch of
different thoughts you know it makes me
makes me think I got a question for you
you know the one thing that a lot of
people are calling me right now you got
a lot of videos that have gone viral
right now on YouTube on a lot of
different topics and you know we're
getting hit up left and right I had a
bio warfare guy in here in a pandemic
expert here one of them is a former
colonel and the other one is a
lieutenant colonel and we had general
Spaulding here from Air Force and we're
talking about China a lot of topics
about China and you're seeing all this
data right now if you're turning on the
news you're not going to be able to
watch your news for more than 20 seconds
without hearing or crawling a virus or
China just keeps coming up left and
right left and right this is an
interesting question for you because I
have an answer for this I'm curious to
know what you say - this is Robert how
how do how does a viewer who has all
this content being hit up all over the
place you know how does a viewer
decipher between the level of
credibility being given to any of these
conspiracy theories that are being
spread and to know what is factual what
is just people who have a lot of time on
their hands who sit there and panic and
they're worried and they share all this
fear and people are sitting there
looking at the stuff with a full level
of credibility how do you decipher
between reality the truth facts and
conspiracy
well they there's another guy is talking
about
of ours at so Martin's and Chris
Martenson and he and Adam Taggart his
partner in the business they thought the
most important thing you got to have is
your team you're your core support group
team yeah well and people talk about
team all the time but this is what
fuller taught me it's a synergy of
different professions so I have I have a
bookkeeper you know people have
QuickBooks
I have bookkeeper a human being I have
Tom wheelwright my accountant as my tax
guy
if Garret sent my general counsel you
know I have Kenny McLeroy who runs my
death department he's my partner in real
estate and we have Josh and Lisa Lannon
who are into addictions because we're
all addicted to something - food Chinese
food but anyway you know that sense I'm
gaining weight sitting at home because
of my addiction so the most important
thing is is to have the integrity of a
team a team that will call you when
you're all out of line or at least
question you because we we all have a
light side and a dark side
and my dark side is very dark I quite
enjoy it and you know you could call it
negative but the reason I am prepared
today is I don't trust my government I
don't trust the Fed you know when I read
crunch of giants and I'm gonna wrote
this book here faint you know this is
2019 fake money fake teachers fake
assets it's fake money the fiat currency
that's why I recommend Bitcoin and gold
and silver just because they're outside
the system you know
bitcoin is open source so you know the
feds gonna come after all I know they're
gonna come after and so they're gonna
create their own Bitcoin because that's
my Satoshi Nakamura he says I don't know
I don't know if he's really either but
he disappeared from sight you know
because he came out in 2009 right after
the subprime crash in 2008 I think here
there was disappeared or he was smart
enough to disappear because you're
messing with
very very big players do you know like
I'm messing with the academic system and
the finance system and when I crossed
into coronavirus and the pandemic I was
warned you know I was pounded pounded on
social media they said you stay out of
this one because pharmaceuticals and
insurance is big business so the thing
is is the most important thing is I
selected book Atlas Shrugged you know
the cap let's go into hiding and so I'm
I have several places where I hide but I
also hide like we're hiding right now in
plain sight in social media so I get
together unzoom with my team and all
this and we might broadcast my level
meeting to show you what a real team
looks like what a real business team you
know rugby team is one team football is
one team soccer is one team but if you
ever see how real business team is
interesting so we're a small
entrepreneurial group but we're produce
incredible results I mean I make
millions tax-free because I play by the
same rules the corporation's do if
you're us if you're a pizza shop owner
you're playing by the small rules so
you've got to have these good advisors
and all this I always have general
counsel and I don't want to break the
rules but when social media they found
out of me stay out of stay out of the
virus you know don't talk about Bill
Gates having human testing yesterday
Jesus that was fast
but I understand vaccines you know
vaccine to be profitable must be driven
by the government it must be a hundred
percent compliance so they get you know
let's say I don't know what vaccines the
kids have today but a lot of people a
lot of parents want vaccine their kids
and what social media does to get the
other parents to attack that parent and
say you're damaging my kids say well
I've loved my kids you don't love your
kids so I you know I don't vaccine
because I love my kids I'm vaccine
because I love my kids and really what
is fear and that's why it got to be a
wartime leader because I never hated the
Vietcong I respected them
you know they were just like you and me
I hate it when I saw their families die
I hate it when we killed him I didn't
make me happy do you know it was this
lot well we also fight out of fear who
was making us fight
I don't know today you know look at this
way Patrick six million Jews were killed
by the Nazis but Stalin also killed 25
million other people in their gulags I
don't know how many people China's
killing I think that's what we're
getting to you know all of this
political correctness you can't say this
you can say that gender pronouns exactly
I think Jordan feels and talks about
this First Amendment they're taken away
our First Amendment and that's what
Stalin had to do and Mao had to do
you're so afraid of saying it talking to
anybody and then social dissed you know
this thing about you can't congregate
that's First Amendment to the right to
assemble so there's tipping on the
Constitution and so being a sick
individual I said well I'm really glad I
have a second Amendment rights because
my social distancing I can hit at 250
yards I'm very good with a gun but I was
trained to do that
you know we're trained to kill people so
my social distancing is I have a very
powerful arsenal